una violenta tarde en este pana kertz la
capital de la región de nagorno karabaj
a tanto las autoridades de la zona como
el gobierno armenio denuncian que los
bombardeos fueron dirigidos por
azerbaiyán hacia esta ciudad que
amaneció en medio de la zozobra
azerbayán también acusa armenia de
atacar objetivos civiles engancha la
segunda ciudad en importancia en el
oeste de su país allí hago lleva de 72
años la despertó una explosión
un misil que cayó cerca y destruyó las
ventanas de su casa y aterrorizó a su
familia
los niños estaban durmiendo justo ahí
pero no se lastimaron yo sólo vine y los
saque y ellos se escaparon
la devastación se ve en las calles de
ganja a 100 kilómetros del límite con
nagorno karabaj a las autoridades
azerbaiyanas dicen que cuatro misiles
cayeron en barrios residenciales de esta
ciudad que mataron a una persona e
hirieron seriamente a otras
para algunos nuestra presencia a causa
de hostilidad y un sentido de injusticia
ellos son de francia son de francia yo
no trabajo para el gobierno francés
bueno dígales muéstreles ellos
simplemente eran civiles estamos lejos
de nagorno karabaj o este parlamentario
local está dispuesto a difundir el
mensaje oficial
estos misiles vinieron directamente
desde armenia quieren que respondamos y
ataquemos territorio armenio
las autoridades de azerbaiyán alegan que
esta provocación desde armenia busca
prolongar el conflicto
armenia niega rol alguno en los
bombardeos y dice que estos fueron
dirigidos por las fuerzas de nagorno
karabaj a quienes dicen que buscaban
atacar instalaciones militares